this video is sponsored by the book
summary service blankest the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive free unlimited
access for one week plus 25% off a full
membership Carl sat on his couch looking
back and forth between his phone and the
ceiling trying to figure out whether he
was about to move ten thousand miles
away to Australia leaving his home
girlfriend family friends job and whole
life behind or not the opportunity to
move had suddenly come up when his best
friend Novak decided he would be moving
to Australia with his girlfriend and
aged 27 Novak was facing a sort of
quarter life crisis and wanted to try
and start something new and venture out
into the world while he still felt knew
himself moving to Australia had been
both Novak and Carl's dream ever since
they were children and their families
vacation there they both felt a weird
natural connection with the colors
architecture people and feeling of the
country they visited again several times
after throughout their teens and early
20s on one of their trips when they were
15 Carl and Novak agreed that they would
move there when they were older that and
they would start a business together
this would remain their dream ever since
as they grew older though like most
dreams it began to take a backseat to
reality Carl went to college for
accounting in his hometown of Boston and
got a job through a professor right
after school that he couldn't turn down
Novak had a family member in a tech
startup company in Boston and as a
result he was given an opportunity to
work for the company however after four
years of Novak working for the company
it was suddenly acquired and he was out
of a job as part of the layoffs he was
provided with the nice-sized severance
package and now with some new extra
money and nothing else stopping him he
decided he wanted to start a business
and take a major leap of faith in his
life his girlfriend somewhat of a free
spirit was on board with him Novak came
up with the idea of moving to Australia
and creating an eco-friendly Agrotech
company that utilized Australia's
farming industry and its demand for
local farm-fresh organic food one month
later
Novak told Carl that he and his
girlfriend were moving to Australia
within the next couple months he told
him about the business idea that he and
his girlfriend worked on together and
showed him the Bata website and app he
created
it looked and sounded great and
well-thought-out Novak's girlfriend had
experience working in logistics and
novak understood the business and
technology side they were the perfect
duo when Karl didn't fully understand
novak explained to him that he wanted
him to be a partner in the business and
that he should move to australia with
them
he told Karl it would be perfect and he
could initially be in charge of sales
marketing outreach budgeting and all the
finances he reminded karl of their dream
and told him how would only get harder
to move and try to create something like
this he sort of ridiculed the idea of
Karl staying in Boston and working a
corporate job for the rest of his life
as if that's what he really wanted he
told Karl how this business had a real
chance to help people how they could
build a business model that would
provide families with food who couldn't
afford it and help the planet by
contributing to a more sustainable food
industry Karl agreed with Novak's points
but told him that he needed a couple
days to think about it at least novak
agreed and told them to let him know
after he thought about it more over the
next day karl thought about all the
factors associated with the decision he
thought about how his mother had
recently passed away just two years
prior and he and his father had become
extremely close ever since his father
was not taking it well and Karl's older
brother had a strained relationship with
his father and so in a way Karl was all
his father had left he worried that if
he left it would break him Karl also
thought about his girlfriend Stephanie
they had only been dating a little more
than a year but he had already started
imagining a future with her things were
going well and they just seemed to click
right
he knew that he couldn't expect her to
go with him and he knew a long-distance
relationship was bound to fail if she
even agreed to it he thought about all
his other friends and family he knew it
wasn't as if they would cease to exist
but he also knew that in a way their
existence would fade a little perhaps so
much so for some that it would almost be
as if they no longer existed at all then
he thought about his current job he
worked for a great firm with great
benefits and he'd finally started making
some headway in the company there was a
lot of financial promise ahead of him
and he knew it was the more prudent
career bet but then at the same time he
thought about how a greater risk meant a
potentially greater reward he didn't
mind his current job but it was fairly
tedious and unexcited he sort of just
happened into it as a means of a
conservative career path he had always
dreamed of being a part of building a
business and creating a more meaningful
impact and legacy for himself
furthermore he never particularly liked
Boston
he had always wanted to move to the
countryside ever since he was a kid
specifically he always envisioned a
future where he lived in Australia it
was just one of those things that he had
convinced himself of and now at 27 Karl
felt an urge to leave home and forge his
own life for himself while he was still
young he wondered how he could turn down
such an opportunity to move to his dream
location with his best friend and try to
build something potentially important
and helpful
how could he turn his back on his own
vision of his future when it was right
in front of him for the following three
days Karl thought about the decision
every waking second ruminating back and
forth between the potential outcomes of
both choices after four days it seemed
as if no matter how hard he tried he
made no progress in the decision he
remained equally unsure as to what he
should do on the fourth day as the first
both options seemed impossible to
decipher it wasn't an equation with
numeric values or obvious reasoning each
option was completely different with
their own entirely different set of
variables and values with no ability to
know what any of it equated to Karl had
purposely held off sharing the situation
with anyone else so to avoid getting
anyone upset before he had a better
sense of what he was going to do himself
but by this point he needed someone
else's opinion over the next two days
Karl told his father his girlfriend two
of his other close friends and his aunt
he asked each of them what they thought
he should do everyone gave him different
answers his dad and one of his friends
said he should go his aunt and his other
friends said he should stay his
girlfriend didn't give him a straight
answer but her tears said everything
Karl needed to know they all had
perfectly good rational explanations for
what they suggested and yet Karl was no
better off he wondered how each answer
could sound equally reasonable but be
completely contradictory on the sixth
night of indecision Karl went on a walk
around the city to try and clear his
head
he walked late into the night all around
the city and along the harbour
eventually he found himself on a bench
facing the water completely secluded in
a sectioned off corner of a pathway
he sat any thought he thought about how
his entire future was hinged on this one
decision contained inside his head that
in his brain was the power to facilitate
one move that would contort his entire
world forever and yet he couldn't even
know what choice was right he thought
about how insane this was to be given
the ability to make decisions but not
given the ability to ever know the
consequences of them he felt like he was
blind and
forced to drive a car you wished he
could just know how both options would
play out then he wouldn't know which one
to choose
overwhelmed Carl looked out at the stars
and moon glimmering against the water he
closed his eyes and took a deep breath
suddenly an older man walked past Carl
and sat on a bench just a couple feet
away this jolted Carl to attention he
was immediately surprised by anyone
being in the same secluded pathway and
was curious as to why a man who looked
to be at least in his 80s would be out
alone at 2:00 a.m.
worried that the man was perhaps unwell
or lost Carl decided to ask him if he
was okay
politely he turned and leaned over to
the man and said how's everything going
tonight the man slowly turned towards
Carl and said good how about yourself
good Carl responded is everything okay
yeah everything's great it's a beautiful
night isn't it replied the old man Carl
looked up to the sky yeah it is he
agreed then they sat quietly as Carl
sort of jumped back and forth between
contemplating his decision again and
being distracted by the man's strange
presence the idea of asking the man his
opinion occurred to Carl he looked over
to the man and asked him if he could ask
him a question yeah sure shoot the man
replied Carl then went on and described
his predicament he explained the
business his job his girlfriend his best
friend his father and everything else
then he asked the old man what he would
do the man laughed a little as if he had
some experience or insight about the
subject that was comical to him so you
want to make the right choice but you
don't know what the right choice is the
old man asked yeah exactly
Carl replied I'm completely lost I wish
I could just know what both would be
like you know yeah if only the old man
said with another chuckle wouldn't that
make everything easier they sat quietly
for a moment while the man thought then
he said what if you just decide right
now based on what I choose someone who
basically doesn't know you at all
it'll be like flipping a coin but the
coin as a brain understands the
situation a little somehow this made
sense to Carl and after thinking for a
moment he agreed he just needed it to be
over the old man paused and then quickly
said alright you're gone in a desperate
clinging to reason Carl asked the old
man what made you choose that I guess
you'll have to find that out replied the
old man Carl sat for a moment processing
the fact that he was going to do what
the man just said
then when he got up and went to thank
the man and wish him a good night he was
gone
Carl figured he must have just left
while he was thinking and didn't hear
him say goodbye five weeks later Carl
was on a plane with Novak and Novak's
girlfriend headed to Australia 20 years
would go by Carl has remained in
Australia ever since he moved he now
considers it home even after 20 years it
still feels amazing to him a walk along
the coast or into the countryside never
ceases to amaze him and bring him a
little peace he and Stephanie broke up
within the first three months of trying
to maintain some form of a long-distance
relationship one and a half years later
he met a woman named Natalie and fell in
love almost instantly they got married
three years later and they now have two
healthy boys who have provided Carl's
life with a great source of purpose and
love Carl Novak and Novak's girlfriends
business ran for about six years until
unforeseen industry changes operational
problems and regulations forced them to
shut it down
they had tried pivoting the business
model several times before it failed all
with no luck during this time however
Carl discovered a surprisingly strong
passion for the farming process himself
a year after the original business ended
Carl bought a small indoor farm facility
and started his own personal farming
business the business became profitable
in the first three years but the profit
ceiling is low and it brings in a fairly
small amount of money each month his
wife who works as a freelance copywriter
doesn't bring in much money either
because of the low income and the
expenses of two children the financial
burden made Carl and Natalie horrible
and bitter to one another their
personalities just never quite clicked
after the early phases of the marriage
they've stayed together for the kids but
they're miserable Carl and Novak have
remained close during and after the
business and have formed a nice little
friend group with others they've met
along the way even though the original
plan didn't work out Carl feels
connected with his work and contributing
directly to a local sustainable food
industry gives him the occasional sense
of pride however it has come at the cost
of constant financial burden heavy
stress and minimal free time Carl isn't
happy but he isn't unhappy he's a mix of
both depending on the time or day
as the years went by Karl visited home
less and less he would go home and visit
his father most Christmases and special
occasions but eventually he started
missing a few years here and there the
last time he visited his father was at
his funeral at the service Carl stood
looking down in his father's lifeless
body he looked around at old friends
family members neighbors his brother who
he hadn't seen in five years he looked
at his wife he immediately needed to get
some fresh air after the service was
over he walked to the bar down the
street that he would go to when he was
in his 20s as fate would have it he
passed by Stephanie they noticed each
other hugged and talked for a little
while Carl told her why he was home and
she said she was sorry
it was weird he felt at ease almost as
if they didn't miss a beat he felt more
comfortable with her in that moment than
he had in a long time
after a little they said how great it
was to see each other and went their
separate ways
Carl sat at the bar drinking alone he
thought back to the day he left and felt
a weird sense of regret he wondered if
he did the wrong thing leaving his
father and family and Stephanie leaving
his good job that would have certainly
paid away most of his current problems
he remembered how he let some stranger
make such an important decision for him
and suddenly felt like his regret wasn't
even his which made it feel
exponentially worse
later that night Carl walked around the
city by himself to try to clear his head
he walked down the edge of the city
along the harbor he sat down on the same
bench he sat on many years ago facing
the water he sat back in the bench
looking up at the stars close his eyes
and breathed in deeply he sat there for
a moment suddenly an old man poked Carl
shoulder Carl disoriented opened his
eyes to an old man standing above him
before Carl could say anything the old
man asked him if he was okay
Carl having realized he must have passed
out on the bench told the man he was
fine and just fell asleep the old man
sat on the bench a few feet away as he
explained to Carl how it was unsafe to
fall asleep alone in such an area you're
likely to get robbed to something he
said Carl agreed and said it was an
accident he explained to the old man
that he hadn't been able to get much
sleep the last several days because he
had been trying to make the decision
about whether or not he would be moving
to Australia after talking for a little
while and explaining his predicament
about the business his best friend his
girlfriend his father and everything
else Carl had the idea to ask the old
man what he thought he should do the man
laughed a little as if he had some
experience or insight about the subject
that was comical to him after a little
more conversation the man said what if
you just decide right now based on what
I choose someone who basically doesn't
know you at all
it'll be like flipping a coin but the
coin as a brain understands the
situation a little stricken with a weird
sense of deja vu
Carl agreed he just needed it to be over
the old man paused for a moment and then
quickly said alright you're staying in a
desperate clinging to reason Carl asked
why what made you choose that I guess
you'll have to find that out said the
old man five weeks later Novak was on a
plane for Australia while Carl ate
dinner with Stephanie and his father 20
years would go by
Karla's stayed in the Boston area he has
climbed the ranks in his career field
and has become chief financial officer
for a nice midsize company he is making
an incredible salary he married
Stephanie a couple years after deciding
to stay they decided against having
children because Stephanie was against
it and Carl wasn't sure himself and was
willing to concede over the years their
love grew stronger and stronger they
fight like any couple but there's a
luster in their relationship that's rare
and always present they seem to just
click as if their personalities were
meant to work together their
relationship has provided Carl with a
great source of love and purpose in his
life Carl had also remained close with
his father and helped him into his old
age they've maintained a close bond that
Carl cherishes most of Carl's other
friends however have moved away or
drifted apart Novak and Carl sort of
lost contact as well only seeing each
other once every year so if that with no
children and a higher income money has
never really been an issue and his
personal life is fairly stress-free he
never really came around to liking his
job though as he climbed the corporate
ranks it came with increasing
bureaucratic tedium and he found an
absurdity and pointlessness and it all
the longer he stayed though the harder
it was to leave as he's aged he's felt a
sense of boredom hollowness and social
isolation in his life he isn't happy but
he isn't unhappy he's a mix of both
depending on the time or day on his 40th
birthday Karl had a party Novak flew out
along with a couple other old friends at
the party Karl spent a good deal of time
catching up with Novak and Novak told
him all about the last couple years in
Australia he told them how his three
kids were doing and how well the
business was doing Karl asked Novak
about some details in the business and
Novak explained how their third partner
who they had found when they first moved
and had helped them get the business
through some hard times was now playing
a key role in the business moving into
foreign markets he told Karl the
business was helping thousands of
families each month and he was extremely
proud of it then he told karlie wished
he would have been the person he was
talking about instead Karl saw the pride
and enthusiasm in Novak's eyes when he
spoke about his children and his
business Karl looked around at his
co-workers at his apartment he suddenly
felt a sense of doubt and regret in his
life's path he wondered if he did the
wrong thing he thought about how he let
some stranger make such an important
choice for him the worst part wasn't
even that his life was bad or good with
that in this moment it almost felt like
it wasn't even his to regret at the end
of the night after mostly everyone went
home Karl went on a walk around the city
by himself
moderately drunk he walked down the edge
of the city along the harbor he sat down
on the same bench he sat on many years
ago facing the water he sat back in the
bench looked up at the Stars
closed his eyes and breathed in deeply
suddenly an old man poked Karl in the
shoulder Karl disoriented opened his
eyes to an old man standing above him
before Karl could say anything
the old man asked if he was okay Karl
having realized he must have passed out
told the man he was okay and just fell
asleep the old man sat on the bench a
few feet away as he explained to Karl
how it was unsafe to fall asleep in such
an area he likely to get robbed or
something
he said Karl agreed and said it was an
accident he explained to the old man
that he hadn't been able to get much
sleep the last several days because he
had been trying to make the decision
about whether or not he would be moving
to Australia
Karl explained the situation about the
business his best friend his girlfriend
his father and everything else as he did
Karl felt a weird sense of clarity he
couldn't put his finger on it but he
almost felt like he knew what each
decision would be like like he had
already lived them
but yet despite this he still had no
clue which one was better while Carl was
thinking about this suddenly the old man
interrupted what if he just decide right
now based on what I choose someone who
basically doesn't know you at all
it'll be like flipping a coin but the
coin has a brain and understands the
situation a little Carl thought for a
moment and then politely said no I I
think I need to decide for myself
thank you though I thought you said you
couldn't figure out which choice was
right said the old man how are you gonna
get past that I guess I'm not replied
Carl I spent the last week trying to
figure out which choice was right but
maybe there isn't a right choice maybe
there's just a choice what do you mean
by that interrupted the old man maybe
some decisions aren't hard because
there's a better option but because
there isn't one this whole time I've
been worried about regretting my choice
by choosing the wrong thing as if I
could even know what I'm regretting
regret would mean there was a right
choice and I made the wrong one but how
could there be a wrong one the only
thing I can know is that on the other
side of the decision I'll be there and
if I'm there no matter what path I go
they'll always be something to love and
there will always be something to dread
and the only thing to regret would be
not making the decision for myself if
you pick it if anyone else picks it if I
leave it up to chance it'll never be
mine or at least it won't feel like it
so how do you suppose you choose now I
guess I do my best pick one and move on
replied Carl it won't be chance it won't
be certainty we'll be somewhere in
between and it'll be the right choice
so said the old man with a continued
smile which are you going to choose
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blink Asst
blink astiz a book summary service that
provides overviews and essential
takeaways from thousands of non-fiction
books by condensing complete books down
to around 15 minute audio and written
summaries blink is - makes it easy to
ingest the key ideas and frameworks of a
book in a short convenient amount of
time covering an array of nonfiction
genres with a wide variety of subjects
and areas like philosophy science
technology health business and much more
Linkous provides a diverse inventory of
authors and titles for just about anyone
if you're interested in works of
philosophy Linkous has great titles like
free will by sam harris the wisdom of
insecurity by alan watts letters from a
stoic by seneca as well as plenty more
if you're interested in science or
futurism Linkous also has great titles
like out-of-control by Kevin Kelly and a
brief history of time by Stephen Hawking
perhaps what's most helpful about
blankest
is that it allows you to easily
determine whether or not you are
interested in a particular author or
book without having to invest too much
time into finding out with comprehensive
overviews plinkus makes it easy to
discover whether or not a book is what
you are looking or hoping for allowing
you to judge more efficiently whether or
not you are interested in reading the
full version with free time and
attention spans constantly being
challenged this can be very helpful in
engaging in more effective reading and
learning a 7-day trial is completely
free and can be cancelled at any time
within the trial period the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access as well as 25% off a
full membership again if you're
interested please visit blinkers comm
slash pursuit of wonder or click the
link in the description thanks so much
for watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you